[موسيقى]
مليشيا الحوثيه الارهابيه نائبه اكثر من
45 مليار من البنك المركزي في الحديده
وكان وفقا الاتفاقيه السكر كانت مخصصه
لمرتبات الموظفين همم في مناطق سيطره
الميليشيات همم الارهابيين السعوديه
والرغم ذلك انه يبات هذه الميليشيات ولم
يحرك ساكنه من المجلس الامن ولا حتى
بايداننا لهذه المبالغ الماليه التي نهي
بها الحوثيون من البنك المركزي فرع
الحديده همم ويسخرونها لخدمه
[موسيقى]
كلما قدمت لهم حوافز من المجتمع الدولي او
المجتمع الاقليمي كلما هم غلبو مصلحه
ايران على مصالح الشعب اليمني واستمروا في
هذه الاعمال الارهابيه وممارسه العنف ضد
الشعب اليمني ضد النساء ضد الاطفال ضد
الممتلكات الخاصه
والعامه
كل هذه القضايا ارتكبتها وهي لا تختلف عن
ممارسات داعش والقاعده يعني انت لو ما
تقارن بين ما تعمل ما تعملوا هذه المشكله
وما تقوم به من افعال اجراميه ضد الشعب
اليمني وتقارنها بالافعال التي تقوم بها
منظمه القاعده وداعش ستجد انها لا تختلف
تماما
[موسيقى]